As if Batman didn't have enough problems,
he's now facing accusations of thievery.
Since camera test footage of star Robert Pattinson
suited up for writer-director Matt Reeves'
The Batman was made public last week, some
fans have been taking to social media to pan
the new getup.
It's not DC die-hards that are doing most
of the dissing, though.
It's Marvel fans, who seem to think that Battinson's
mask bears a little too much of a resemblance
to that worn by the Devil of Hell's Kitchen
in the Netflix series Daredevil.
It doesn't help that the footage was absolutely
bathed in a candy apple red glow, which has
the effect of making the Dark Knight's suit
look as if it's been dyed Daredevil Red, and
is also reminiscent of the Netflix series'
opening credits.
Of course, the camera test footage didn't
give us a head-to-toe gander at the new Batsuit.
It mostly lingered on the chest piece, along
with the mask and cowl.
It never does show us Bruce Wayne's Bat-ears,
which are typically set much further back
from the forehead than Daredevil's trademark
horns.
So the similarity between the new Batsuit
and Daredevil's duds might not be quite so
pronounced once we get a full-color, top-to-bottom
peek.
It's tough to argue, though, that the mask
Battinson is sporting with its shaped brow,
nose guard, and opening for the mouth and
chin that's cut nearly all the way back to
the temple doesn't look pretty Daredevil-esque.
A strong contingent of Marvel fans came out
on Twitter to jeer at the new Batsuit pretty
much immediately after the test footage was
released.
More than a few fans just angrily pointed
out the resemblance, like this user, who tweeted,
"I mean did they even try?"
"These questions are vital ones."
While others at least had a sense of humor
about the whole thing, like this user, who
tweeted,
"If Daredevil could see The Batman right now
he would be pissed."
As always, though, there were a few voices
of reason amid the chorus of boos.
Deciding to go ahead and address every criticism
thus far leveled at Pattinson's Caped Crusader,
one user wrote,
"Dear people still upset about the new Batman.
The suit and cowl is fine.
Yes that [looked] like Daredevil, it's not
just cause he's in red light.
It's the shape of the cowl.
Robert Pattinson has other roles aside from
Twilight.
Watch The Lighthouse.
He doesn't need to be buff."
We've been saying ever since the casting was
announced that Pattinson is a criminally underrated
actor who is going to make an absolutely fantastic
Batman.
Need proof?
First, there's the 2017 crime drama Good Time,
which stars Pattinson as a bank robber desperately
trying to gather funds to get his simple-minded
brother out of prison.
The flick was directed by the Safdie brothers,
who turned in one of the sharpest thrillers
in recent memory with last year's Uncut Gems.
Pattinson's performance in Good Time has been
hailed by critics as both brilliant, and about
as far from Edward Cullen as you can get.
"As if you could outrun me!"
Next, we direct you to 2018's High Life, a
sci-fi/drama from acclaimed French director
Claire Denis.
Pattinson stars as a condemned prisoner aboard
a deep-space mission bound for a black hole,
and the movie's crazy, non-linear narrative
is absolutely anchored by his committed performance.
Speaking of committed performances, you'd
also do well to follow the advice of the Twitterer
above and watch The Lighthouse, in which Pattinson
totally holds his own in what is essentially
a two-man acting showcase opposite the great
Willem Dafoe.
"Easy!"
"Quit your flailing, lad!"
"I ain't!"
"Y'ar!"
All of the above movies are far from your
typical Hollywood fare, and they all demonstrate
that Pattinson is an actor of impressive range
who is more than capable of delivering an
interesting new take on Bruce Wayne.
As for that Daredevil-y cowl... let's just
reserve judgment until we see some actual,
non-test footage, shall we?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.